쇼! 왓섬맨은 왔소! 오늘은 어디?
바로바로 침착맨의 스튜디오 이렇게 여러분들을 찾아왔는데요!
아우 반갑습니다. 왓섬맨 박준영님 오셨습니다.
안녕하세요. 제가 4년 만에 다시 돌아왔는데
진짜로 제일 핫하드는 침착맨의 프로그램에 나오겠습니다.
난 맨 처음에는 참치맨인 줄 알았어요.
하지만 침착맨 와갖고 이렇게 이런 자리에도 오게 됐어요.
여기 라이브 들어가기 전에 살짝 앞에 좀 살짝 찍었거든요.
그때도 이제 사인을 해주셨는데 침착맨이라고 써주시더라고요.
다른 거예요. 칭찬하고 칭찬.
아 내가 칭찬이라고 썼어요?
아 미안해. 너무 미안해요.
아 근데 좋은 뜻이니까. 칭찬도 좋은 뜻이니까.
아 오히려 나 바꾸려고요. 침착맨으로 바꾸려고요.
아 저게 더 멋있어요.
아 미안해. 아 그러니까 이게 이게 이
씹다수 같은 거죠.
아 씹다수에요. 씹다수.
영 재주 씹다수.
이게 어 침착 칭찬 참치 치우시도록 하면 나한테 다 비슷하게 들려서
발음이 좀 약간
네 비슷해서
꼬이기도 하고
아 그래서 들어가기 전에 얘기를 해봤는데
굉장히 호기심이 많으시더라고요.
아 난 되게 호기심이
뭐 하나 딱 꽂히시면은 이야기를 이렇게 쭉 가시던데
그래가지고 아까 얘기를 하다가 좀 말이 통한 부분이 있었는데
제가 옛날에 이제 개인 방송할 때 이런 말을 했었거든요.
옛날 애니메이션 특유의 움직임이 좋다.
그런 말들을 했었어요.
여러분들 아셔야 될 게 뭐냐면은
요새 친구들은 잘 모를 수도 있지만
이 친구랑 저는 진짜 애널럭스
진짜로 테레비 뭔지 알지 가서 우리가 틀어야 되는
진짜 애널럭스부터 중간에 조금 짝퉁 디지털
요런 식의 디지털 짝퉁 디지털에서
짝퉁 디지털
지금 우리는 여기 진짜 디지털 세대로 왔는데
우리는 그 중간중간 트랜지셔널 페이즈라고 그러죠.
여기서 여기로 넘어갈 때 그거를 다 봤기 때문에
그게 되게 풍부하게 느껴지는데 옛날 만화 손으로 그린 거
스탑모션이나 요런 거 한 장 한 장씩 한 거
그게 뭔가 깊이가 있고 이브멘트가
풍부해요 확실히
풍부하고 더 따뜻하고 굵직한데 음악도 똑같아요.
요새 여러분들 아시다시피 여기 어린 친구들은 모를 수도 있지만
나이 쯤 있으신 분들은 카세트 테이프 아니면 LP 아니면 CD를 들었을 때
좋은 오디오 시스템으로 들으면 집체적이고
내가 그 음악 속 안에 들어간 것 같고 완전 3D예요.
근데 그게 들어가서 온 거 아니야?
음악은 옛날 음악은 아무리 녹음 환경을 막 좋게 해도
미묘한 그 공기 소리 같은 게 들어가서
그래서 약간 풍부하게 느껴져서
랩 같은 것도 사실은 이 2Pac이나 이런 랩 하시는 분들 들어보면
사실은 밀당 요런 게 있고 지금 박자 어긋나는 거 요런 게 있는데
요새 거는 너무 완벽해
너무 깔끔하니까
그게 진영이가 JYP가 좀 그래요
걔는 너무 깔끔하고 되게 완벽한 걸 좋아하기 때문에
아 그러면 이렇게 하면 안 돼요?
형님 생각에 지금 JYP는 잘못된 방향으로 하고 있다
JYP 뭔지 알지?
얘는 뭔가 했을 때 모든 게 완벽해야 돼
모든 게 딱딱딱딱딱딱딱 맞아야 되는
나는 조금 뭔가 좀 밀리는 그 느낌
약간 약간 불완전하기 때문에 매력적이고
그 뭔가 그 계속 중독성이 있는 그 맛을 누리는데
누리고 거기 끝에 가서 딱 맞춰주면 되는데
근데 뭐 진영이가 나보다 훨씬 돈 더 많고
성공을 많이 했기 때문에 내가 아무 말도 못하겠지만
완벽주의자고 내가 사랑하는 진영이입니다
완벽주의자 근데 좀 약간 흉처럼 말하는 거 같은데
좋게 말하면 완벽주의자고 나쁘게 말하면 죽여버리는
Q. 진영이의 매력은?
불완전하기 때문에 좀 재밌는
맞아요 항상 스릴이 있어요
아 근데 요즘에는 아무래도 컴퓨터로 많이 하다 보니까
오차 같은 것들도 많이 이제 줄어들었잖아요
그게 이제 장점이자 지금 단점인 것 같은데
맞아요
그런 맛들도 있는데
너무 박준영 부모님 둘 다 한국인 말
한국 사람 맞아요 김치찌개
성북동 제1병원에서 태어나고 애기 때 미국으로 가서
한국 사람 100% 하지만 머리는 보면은
한국 사람 아닐 수도 있지
아 만져봐도 될까요?
아 만져봐도 돼
아 한국 사람 아닐 수도 있어요
아 이거 엄청 두껍네요 이거
머리가 발이 그거 잘라서 여기 밑에 밟잖아
그럼 발 찔고 들어가 머리가 뭐 지금 완전
형님 머리를 계속 기르면 여기 계속 올라가죠
머리가 저는 계속 올라가요
저기 지금 천장 닿을걸요
제가 어렸을 때 오토바이 타고 다녔을 때
백인 자식들 내 친구들은 머리가 진짜 멋있게 이렇게 날려
나는 오토바이 타면 어떻게 되는지 이래요
아 undertake
벌레 새끼들 다 잡고 그리고 또 빨간불 딱 돼서 씬도 서지 않아
그럼 다른 애들 머리가 쭈아아악 멋있게 내려와
나는 이렇게 서있어 그게 내 졸업사진
그 유명한 졸업사진
그게 제가 노력해서 만든게 아니고 그렇게 됩니다
제 사촌 형도 이런 머리 헤어스타일이었거든요
이게 좀 모질도 좀 비슷하고 강하고
명절 때 감도 뭐 이케 해줄거 아니에요
근데 감씨를 이제 잃어버린 거에요
ㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋㅋ
들어가는데 못찾아요 박혀가지고 그냥 계세요
찾다보니까 여기서 빛도 나오고 감시를 찾으려고 한 건데
이런 경우가 있어요?
저는 여기다가 내가 샤워를 하고 모자를 그냥 쓰고 나와서 그렇지만
여기다가 이런 거 그냥 여기다 이런 거 그냥 꽂아도 돼
그냥 꽂으면 어 어디 갔지 하지만 여기 있습니다였구나
머리가 그냥 뭐 아우 진짜 숱이 많아
부모님이 한국인이라고 하셨는데 전에 뭐 쇼프로 같은 데서도 말씀을 하셨더라고요
어머니께 그 주인공이 형님이고 사실은 짜장면이 아니고 잡채
어 사실 잡채
잡채가 왜였었냐면 그 짧게 얘기해서 엄마가 직장 생활을 했을 때
반인들이 미국에서 자기 음식들을 하나씩 갖고 와요
뭐 엄마가 뭐 전을 갖고 오면 이 사람 잡채 갖고 오면
다 같이 나눠서 점심식사도 먹으면 엄마 이제 자기가 먹지 않고 싸서 와갖고 나한테 줘
그럼 내가 엄마도 잡채 먹으면 엄마는 잡채 싫어해
그런 다음에 내가 다 먹지 않고 엄마 남겨주면 또 엄마는 그거 싸갖고
그 다음날 나 학교 갈 때
그럼 내가 엄마도 잡채 먹으면 엄마는 잡채 싫어해
그 다음날 나 학교 갈 때 그거를 포장해서 줘요
요새야 뭐 어 코리아 뭐 뭐 뭐 갈미불고기 뭐
빈정 대신 어 코리아
미국 사람들 빈정 대신 거였어
옛날에는 왜 그렇게 안 좋았냐는 식으로
그렇지 옛날에는 왜 그렇게 안 좋았냐
이런 요새야말로 K드라마 K팝 좋아하지만
옛날에는 내가 잘 안 좋아한 거야
잡채 갖고 왔는데 나한테 뭐라지 이랬어
어 그거 지렁이라고
근데 그거 침 뱉고 그래갖고 거기서 또 싸우면 노래에서 이래서
불려주소 하니
또 끌려오셔서. 그게 그 부분이죠.
잡초에다가 테러를 했어요.
그때는 비디오에서는 장혁한테 침뱉고
막 이랬지만 그 당시에 미국에
침뱉고 그래서 어머님은
짜장면이 싫다고 하셨어.
제 스토리입니다. 그러면은
그때 싸움을 많이 하셨을 거 아니에요.
그럼 승률이 좀 어땠어요?
그게
싸움하지 않고 거의 의도 맞았죠.
일주일에 한
두세 번은 맞고 오지.
1대 다로 이렇게 되는 경우?
한 명은 아니에요. 대부분 보면 세 명에서 한 다섯 명
씩 오죠. 차라리 가만히 있으면 나아.
맞다가 나중에는
싸우게 됐지. 다시. 그래서
저는 그냥 진짜 살아남으려고
싸운 거였었지. 자랑스러운 거 아니에요.
싸우는 거 안 좋아하면 뭔지 알지. 구독자 여러분
싸우지 말고 뭔지 알지.
말로 하는 게 최고야.
말로 말로 뭔지 알죠.
알겠습니다. 그 아썸맨
처음에 하실 때는
카메라를 직접 들고 돌아다니는 식으로
했잖아요. 자기를 직접 찍으면서.
진짜 제일 싫어요. 그거를 하다가 안 했잖아요.
처음에는 했는데. 왜냐하면
그걸
이제 얘네들이 그렇게 해야 된다는데
나는 알다시피 나 말할 때
손 되게 많이 움직이는 스타일인데
이걸 하니까 그냥 안 되는 거야.
하니까 이제 PD가 보고
야 이거 빼자. 왜냐하면 쭌이 형이 이거 때문에
답답해서 말을 못하는 것 같아. 그래서 뺐지.
근데 오프닝 할 때만 요 아썸맨 왔어
오늘은 어디? 한담해. 야 갖고 가.
이렇게 됐지. 갖고 가. 싫어.
사실 이거
아썸맨이 처음에 나왔을 때
엄청나게 인기를 좀 얻고
편집 스타일 있잖아요. 특이해. 막 빠른
빨리 빨리. 딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱딱.
어떻게 보면 그때 당시에 되게 정신없다고
까지 할 정도로. 그렇지. 그게 왜 좋았었냐면
우리나라 분들이 되게 마음이 급해.
엄청 급하기 때문에 어떤 사람들은
영화 볼 때 야 이거 중간 건너뛰고
빨리 끝만 보자. 이런 스타일이기 때문에
편집을 그렇게 했는데 맨 처음에 짜증나는
사람들 있었는데 사람들이 보다가
오 이거 좋다. 적응을 해버렸어. 적응을 해버린 거야.
이것도 사실은 맨 처음에 우리가
하려고 했을 때는 대본 같은 게 있었어.
나한테 뭐 음악의 시인처럼 해주자고.
나는 연기는 특히나 한국말로
연기하면 되게 어색하고 난 이거 싫고
우리 그냥 대본 없이 프리로 가자.
했을 때 이거 편집할 때도 어려울 거고
우리 진행할 때도 어려울 거라고. 아 그냥 하자.
해갖고 했는데 터져버린 거야.
알다시피 난 말하는 건 되게 좋아하고
우리 얘기하면 유랑 나랑 한 10시간
동안 계속 쭉 말할 수 있잖아.
6시간 촬영한 건데
8분소 12분.
출연했기 때문에 그렇게
편집 스타일이 더 그렇게 된 거야.
효율이 엄청 안 나와. 그렇지. 왜냐하면 맨날 이렇게 영상 나오면
옛날 얘기가 나오니까 컷 이렇게 얘기하는데
그때 옛날 얘기가 어느 정도 길이로
옛날 얘기를 하게 되면 대부분
한 6분소 한 10분?
이분이 최소.
그게 옛날 얘기야.
길게 가면 30분까지도 가요.
나는 솔직해서요. 여러분들이 아시다시피
저는 어디 가면은
옛날 얘기나 이야기를 되게 오래 해.
맞아요. 그리고 디테일하게 해요.
스토리텔링 하려면은
처음부터 끝까지 다 얘기해 주는데잖아.
그렇죠. 하나를 빼면은 뭔가 나도 아쉽고
내가 왜 그게 재밌었는지를 모를 거 아니야.
그 디테일을 놓치잖아.
그렇지. 근데 얘네들은 그걸 다 했는데
사람들이 그걸 좋아해.
왜냐면 너무 말이 길어지는
그래서 우리가 언젠가는 그냥 옛날 얘기들만 하는 그걸 할 때.
그래서 우리가 언젠가는 그냥 옛날 얘기들만 하는 걸 할 때.
그때 내가 또 출제돼서
유우도 옛날 얘기하잖아.
여기도 진착된 플러스가 있잖아.
우리도 뭐 워스맨 플러스 같은 거 만들 수도 있지.
숏츠가 아닌 럼으로.
그럼 그때 어땠는지에 대해서만
그때 그 시절 얘기도 좀 하고
그렇지.
컨텐츠 얘기도 하고
나는 진짜로 하고 싶은 얘기들이 하도 많고
진짜로 제 생각엔 근데 그렇게 하면은
그거 좋아하는 사람들
나는 어쩔 때 진짜로 유튜브 볼 때
어쩔 때 보면은
짧은 거 보고 싶을 때도 있지만
긴 거 보고 싶을 때
긴 거 보고 싶을 때도 있어요.
그럼 뭐 유튜브에 많잖아요.
맞아요.
난 다큐 같은 걸 너무 좋아해요.
아니면 뭐
이 세상에서 제일 큰 오이
이 세상에서 제일 조그만 강아지
뭐 이런 거 있잖아요. 신기한 거.
그런 거 보는 거 되게 좋아해요.
아
근데 취급하는 연대가
90년대도 취급 안 하잖아요.
80년대 이전 걸 취급하잖아요.
저는 옷 스타일은
60년대하고 70년대 스타일들을 되게 좋아하고
음악도 그렇고
음악도 저는
70년대하고 80년대 음악이 제일 좋고
옛날에 알잖아요.
옛날에 뭐 들으면 항상 한국 음악도
중간에 기타하고 기타 브레이크도 있고
클라이맥스가 있잖아.
요새는 그런 게 없어졌어.
그걸 줄여가지고 짧게 만드는 거 같은데
그런 거 같아.
노래 길이도 봐.
옛날 노래들은 5분짜리 듣고서
7분 8분으로
그리고 옛날에 항상 뭐
댄스 브레이크 있고
중간에 브레이크 다운 뭐 이런 것도
요새 그런 거 하나도 없어졌잖아.
그래서 이게
왜 이거 지금 얘기하게 됐지?
옛날 얘기
어 옛날 맞아요.
80년대부터 취급을 하신다고
맞아요. 옛날 신발 보면 되게 예쁜 것들도 많고
시계들도 그렇고
예쁜 디테일이 많았었는데
요새는 모든 걸 다 샘플러파이 하려 보니까
한국말도 짧게 아까 뭐였었지?
아까 이제 촬영할 때 악뮤가
악뚱뮤지션을 줄여서 악뮤라고 한 건데
모르시더라고요.
악뮤 왜 그렇게
세종대왕이 한국말을 그렇게 만들어 주셨는데
네가
네가 진짜로 내가 얘기해줄게
근데 뮤지션 자체가 한국말이 아닌데
그렇네.
그러니까 그렇네.
한국말이 아니야.
그런데 내 말은 뭐냐면
엄마가 김치를 열나 맛있게 만들었어.
새우젓 집어넣고
김치 속 집어넣고
고춧가루 집어넣고
모든 거 다
배추 집어넣고
파 집어넣고
다 집어넣어서
그 많은 재료를 했는데
나중에 니 다 빼고 그냥 배추만 주면
그게 뭐야
그게 김치야
그게 김치야 그건 배추지
그러니까 내 말은 뭐냐면
그래서 악뚱뮤지션이라고 해야 된다?
악뚱뮤지션으로 해야 돼
악
똥
지
션
나중에
나중에 그럼 god는 뭐라 그래?
지디라고 부를 거야?
그건 지디는 지디잖아
우린 god
난 박준형이야
근데 악뮤는 당사자들이 줄이고 싶다고 한 건데
아 그래 왜 줄이고 싶은지 모르겠어
나중에 우리 대화가 없어지고 어떻게 되는지 알아?
우리 말할 때 이렇게
아
어
아 다 줄여서
다 줄여
나중에 우리 아무것도 안 할 거야
우리 나중에 다 야채들 돼 있을 거야
집에서 둔다고 하고
아
어
하고 끝
그렇기 때문에 여러분 우리 어린 친구들
말 짧히지
뭔지 알지?
길게 말해
아
뭔지 알지?
오히려 더 길게 말했으면 좋겠어
아 근데 형님이 몇 년생이시죠?
내가 1969년도 7월 22일
69년도도 근데 좀 줄인 말이 있지 않아요?
뭐 맞어
미국에서도 줄였네
USA
다 줄이는 거야 그거는
United States of America
미친놈들이네 왜 줄였어
왜 줄였냐고
United States of America
얼만큼 멋있는데 왜 USA로 줄였지
줄이지 말고 사실은 god도 줄이긴 줄인 거야
god도
grove of the
우리 god는 우리도 나빴네
잘못했네
잘못됐어 미안해
내가 잘못했어
근데 god는 그거 줄임말이
팀원들이 정한 거야 아니면 뭐 회사에서 정한 거야?
아 회사에서 정한 거야
사실은 god라고 하지 않고
작은 남자들이라고 나오려고 그랬어
작은 남자
작은 남자들 아니면 작은 신 뭐 뭐였더라
신의 자식이라는 뜻으로 작은 남자들
그렇지 그렇지 그렇지
아 근데 이때 처음에 나왔을 때 반향이 엄청났잖아요
아 그렇지
근데 그때 당시에 잘됐는데
힘든 시절 얘기하시고 그러셨잖아요
이게 뭐냐면 사실은 맨 처음엔
안 됐지 첫 방송으로 우리 망했지
못 봤지 한밤의 티비 연예
그거 못 봤어요
김태수가 그때 눈깔 아직 다 발전이 안 됐기 때문에
근데 형 지금 눈이 조금 좀 세워졌을 것 같았어
뭔지 세워졌는데 눈 조금 이렇게 보일락 말락 하는
그래서 거기서 조금 좀 우리가 망했었는데
그것 때문에요?
어 그게 아니고 우리는 god는 잘 안 알려줬지만
어머니께라는 노래 잘 알려줬고
그리고 또 우리가 육아의 길이라는 프로그램을 찍었을 때
재민이의 육아의 길
그렇지
god의 육아의 길이에요
그 프로그램이
이제 대중들한테 우리의 다른 모습들을 보여줄 기회가 생기고
아 그거 진짜 재밌어
우리를 진짜 많이 대중들한테 알려줬지
그러면은 또 다시 좀 약간 들어가보세요
왓섬맨이 다시 시작했는데
궁금한 게 떠올랐어요
왓섬맨이 일단 보면은 지금 생각하면
유퀴즈보다 먼저 막 가가지고 사람들 얘기하고
그죠?
of course of course
시민 인터뷰 막 하고
그러면 이제 그 사람들 막 계속 만나는데
재밌는 사람들이 나올 때까지 계속 찾는 거예요?
아니에요 저는
아니면 좀 중간에
섭외에 대한 사람들이 기다리고 있어요
그런 거 없어요
그 섭외에 대한 사람들은 대부분 예를 들어서
우리가 이런 데 왔을 때
아니면 뭐 식당을 얘네들이 미리 잡아놨었다
뭐 리피해 놨다 이런 거는 잡아놨지만
그런 건 원래 있는 거고?
길거리에 섭외에 대한 사람은 합류는 없고
편집되는 건 되게 많아요
어떤 사람들은 할 때는
오후 나 하고 싶어요 이러다가
한 다음에 연락 와
내 껏 빼줄 수 있어요
편집되는 게 많아요
그리고 어떤 사람들은 숨어
발음 피고 있나봐 뭔지 알지
뭐 하는지 모르는 거죠
그러니까 그런 건 내가 조심스러워야죠
아
나는 어렸을 때부터 그렇고 지금도 그렇고
일 안 할 때도 나는 그냥 엘리베이터 타면 가만히 못 있어
엘리베이터 탔는데 생각해보세요
조그만 공간에 있어 한 다섯 명이 있어
근데 나는 뭐 십 몇 층까지 올라가야 돼
이 사람도 같이 가는데 조용히 있는 게 부자연스러운 거거든
사실 말 걸고 싶어
그럼 말 걸어요
그럼 뭐라고 말 걸어요?
나보다 키가 작아
그럼 잠수리가 뭘 걸어?
어 잠수리가 예쁘게 생기셨네요
뭔지 알죠?
머리 향기가 너무 좋네요
그러면 그것은 웃어
그러면서 어 여기서 일하세요
이러면서 말을 시작을 해요
가만히 어떤 사람은 천식이 있으면 천식이도 소리 들리고
코 막힌 사람은 코 숨 쉬는
이런 것보다 말하는 게 낫지
근데 우리나라에서는 엘리베이터에서 말을 잘 안 하잖아요
말 안 해요
나는 그거 탔을 때 진짜로 조용히 있는 게 너무 싫고
가만히 있으면 그 조그만 공간에 냄새가 더 풍부하게 나요
근데 그게 그런 소통을 굉장히 중시하시는데
온라인으로 하는 거는 별로 좋아하지는 않죠
사람들끼리 면대면
어 맞아요
나는 일단 이거 치는 것도 잘 못하고
난 치다가 곧바로 전화 걸잖아요
그럼 형 나 지금 통화 못해
끊어 사람들 이게 된 거야
그러면 만약에 예를 들어 전화를 했어요
문자보다는 전화를 선호하고
전화보다는 만나는 걸 선호할 거 아니에요
그럼 전화를 하다가 딥하게 얘기를 하고 싶으면
좀 근처 살아요 한 20분 30분
만나서 얘기하자 전화하다가
같은 그런 경우도 많아요?
어!
그러면 집 앞에서 뭔지 알지?
야리스 야리스 나비다
말하는 게 너무 좋지
아 그럼 만나서 밥 안 먹었으면 밥 먹었으면
아니 밥 안 먹어도 돼
나는 솔직히 밥 먹을 때는 말을 많이 안 해요
저는 뭐를 하냐면
여기 있는 분들 잘 모르겠지만
나는 어렸을 때
친구들하고 나이트 가는 게 재밌는 것보다도
나이트 끝난 다음에
밥 먹고 주차장에서 야리하면서
얘기하는 게
수다 떠는 게 제일 재밌어
근데 나이트를 가면 수다를 떨 수 있잖아요
아 근데 너무 시끄러워
시끄럽고 짜증나
뭔지 알지?
그런 모르는 사람 와갖고 말하는데
그 사람 귀에다가 막 소리만 지르면
걔네들 그냥 도망가지
아 얘기를 더 하고 싶은데
난 얘기만 하고 싶어
난 얘기하는 건 너무 좋아요
근데 얘기를 하려면
나이트가 끝나고 밖에 나가서
야리 타이밍 때 얘기를 할 수 있으니까
그렇지
그래서 나이트를 간 거예요
맞아
난 술을 안 먹어
그냥 내가 그 당시 할 수 있는 건
야리밖에 없었기 때문에
야리 이렇게 피다가
사람들하고 이야기 나누고
그리고 끝에 가서 진짜 다 같이 가갖고
뭐 고깃집
옛날에 박대간나 이런 데 가서 고기 먹고
햇뜰 때까지 주차장에서 수다 떠는 거지
난 그게 재밌어
그래서 소통하는 거를 굉장히 중시하기 때문에
왓섬맨 처음에 시작하실 때도
대본 없이 그냥 바이브로 가자
바이브로 가는 게 이게 뭐냐면
근데요
일하러 가는데 일하러 가는 거 같지 않고
나만의 소통 타임
나만의 즐거운 타임
내가 평상시에 하는 건데
이제는 이유가 있어
내가 할 수 있는 이유
근데 그런 사람이 계속 안 나타나면 어떡해요
그럼 나 혼자 말하지
솔직히 해서 나도
어느 날 기분 안 좋은데
누가 말 걸면 실치 그러고
카메라 들여다보는 일반 사람들은 익숙되지 않았는데
그렇죠
준비되지 않았으니까
근데 너무 웃긴 게
8년 전하고 지금하고 많이 변했어
사람들이 이제 더 쿨해
도망가는 사람
100명에서 한
3명 정도
3명밖에 없었을 정도로
이제는 사람들이 되게 환영해
왜 그럴까요
모르겠어요
이제 이 문화 자체가 많이 변한 것 같아
카메라에 이제 너무 익숙한 거
그런 것 같아
옛날에는 두둥두둥해서
이거 아니면 너무 나대서 까부른 사람들이
야암! 하면 이 사람한테
뭐 술 찬 사람한테 갔으면 좋겠나
안 돼 갔으면 좋겠나
이제는 그게 아니고 딱 좋게
원래 바이브
어 여유 있게 어 하고 한 다음에
말하면 어 여기 친구랑 왔고
어 형 우리 친구들끼리 왔어
이게 있어 이제
옛날에는 그걸 한다면
말 안 할 거면
안 하고 어 이거 아니면
딱 이랬는데 이제는
밸런스가 딱 좋아졌어
그러면 이제
요즘에 다시 시작한 왔으면
좀 재밌어졌겠네요
뭐 사람들 만나고
네 한편은 내가 어디 가는 데는
거의 지금 좀 조심스러워 돼갖고
첫 촬영이었는데
조심스러운 공간 같아갖고
내가 자유롭게는 못 했는데
두 번째 간 공간은
you know
in the wild
그때는 너무 재밌었었죠
근데 여기서 갑자기 또 궁금한 게 있는데
뺨이 뭔 뜻이에요
뺨이 뭐냐면 한국말로 하면
그 이거지
있는 거예요 미국에 있는 말이에요?
원래
또 옛날에
batman 뭐 스파이더맨
네
거기 보면
누구 때리면
뺨
파우
와우
아 원래 있는 효과음이에요?
어어 원래 쓰는 말
근데 실제로 평상시에도 좀 많이 쓰시고
어 그렇지 그래서 여기 이렇게 내가 만들었잖아
뺨
그래서 내가 그린 거야
뱀이네요
뱀이야 뱀
오
어쩐지 뱀으로
내가 그렸어
아 직접 그리신 거예요?
나 잠깐만 여기
야 저기
화장실에서 그냥 다녀오셔도 돼
아니 진짜
아까 들어가기 전에 얘기를 좀 많이 나눴었어요
몸이 너무 좋으신데
아 이건 따로 관리를 하시냐
그러니까
아 나는 원래 체질적으로
운동을 많이 하셔서
머슬메모리가 좀 있어서
기억이 돼 있다
그래서 운동을 많이 하면은 너무 커져서
자제를 해야 된다
그래서 요즘에 최근에 운동을 자제하면서 한다고
하시더라고요 한 몇 년간
나는 사실 힘들어요
나는 팔이 너무 얇아요
나랑 운동해
아 저는 운동 어떻게 하는지도 몰라요
내가 해줄게
어떻게 해요?
나 원래 대학 다닐 때
트레이너요?
트레이너 했었어
그러니까 자극증 탔지
그런데 운동은
나는 뭐냐면 아까 얘기했듯이
무대 서야 되고 정장 입어야 되고 그러는데
너무 커져
그러면 정장 입으면 뽀대가 안 나
아 근데 그게 그게 멋있는 거잖아요
그게 멋있는 게 아니고
그거는 건달이고
그건 건달이야
딱 정장 핏 입었을 때
멋있게 딱 잘 빠졌는데
벗었을 때 안에
울퉁불퉁
장근육이 빡 있으면
그게 멋있는 거야
뭔지 알지?
KCM님 멋있잖아요
아 그 자식은
KCM님
아 KCM 걔는
걔는 걔는 한 덩어리고
걔는 그냥
걔는 그냥 멋있잖아요
걔는 그거 뭐지
된장 만들기 전에
걔는 뭐지
그 큰 덩어리
메주?
어 메주야
걔는 메주 덩어리야
걔는 그냥 진짜 커
그리고 힘도 엄청 쎄
걔는 쭉 계속 운동을 많이 해왔고
그럼 이제 계속 끊임없이
어느 때쯤에
한 덩치가 어느 때쯤에
아 이거 연상하면 안 되겠다
내가 98kg까지 키웠어
근육으로만?
어 근육으로만
그리고 또
연초 피는 사람들이 쓰면
이건 진짜 연초를 끊으니까
더 붙어요?
그게 아니고 호흡
그리고 스테미나
내가 재작년에 공연했을 때하고
작년에 공연했을 때
하늘 땅 차이인데
내가 연초를 안 핀 지
8월 때 되면 2년 되거든
8년
다른 애들은 끝나고 힘든데
나는 괜찮더라고
담배로 일단 무게를 쥐고 있다가
무게를 벗어나보니까
그런 느낌이야
좀 약간 갑자기
어어어 몸이 막
스테미나도 더 좋고
피콜로 그 갑오처럼
어어어 진짜로
그러고서
아 피콜로
드라이건 버
야 야
야 그리고 누가 나한테
요새 내 머리 스타일 보고 뭐라 그랬지
사탄
미스터 사탄
어 난 미스터 사탄은 야무치였어
뭔지 알지
그 영화 망해야지 하지마
난 야무치였어
여기는 이런 곡을 그냥 아무 말 해도 되는 거네
아무 말 해도 되는 거네
무슨 말을 할 거예요
저 그것도 좀 궁금해요
god
예
요즘에도 공연을 많이 하시잖아요
어느 나라에서 많이 좀 해요
아 우리는 한국
한국에서만 해요
예
어
그 당시
우리가 한참 활동을 했었을 때
그때는 뭐 한류 이런 게 없었어
그러면은
이게 사실 god가
나온 지가 된 그룹이잖아요
예
근데 요즘에 좀 k 뭐 붐이라고 해가지고
뭐 음식이라든지
뭐
뭐 오징어 게임이라든지
뭐 굉장히 관심이 많은데 한국 문화에
예
그러면은 이제 그 외국 팬들이
한국 k-pop만 파다가
전으로 갈 수도 있잖아요
맞아요 맞아요
그러면서 god의 존재를 나중에 알게 되고
예 맞아요
그래갖고 우리한테 많이 오라고 하는 사람들도 있어요
그런데 그게
공연 관계자가요
예
그런데 이제 그거죠
다 각자 다른 소속사들에 있고
다섯 명이서 다 맞히기가 좀 어려워
아
소속사가 아무래도 좀 다르면은
그 조율하기가 훨씬 어려울 것 같아요
맞아요
뭐 이거 말하고 저걸 사는데
뭐 이거 또 가서 또 검토하고 또 이거
왔다 갔다 왔다 갔다 왔다 갔다
그게 제일 어렵죠
그럼 옛날에 활동하실 때
뭐 합숙하고 하실 때는
시간이 딱딱딱 되니까
쭉쭉쭉쭉쭉은 있었겠네요
아우 그때는 뭐 거의
노동자들이었어요
그러니까 소속사에서 이거 해서 내 맹천맹
백회 공연을 내
근데 와
그
우리가 뭐 뭐라고 했는데
백회 공연은 진짜 힘들었었는데
생각해보면 백회 공연 때문에
우리가 지금 어느 공연 장소 가도 떨리진 않아요
라이브는 뭐 그냥
그게 단련이 돼서
단련이 돼서 내가 지금 거의 60인데도
무대에서 3시간 반 동안
라이브로 노래 부르고 춤출 수 있는 거는
그때 훈련 받은 거예요
몸에 익숙돼서 그런 거지
제 친구 중에도
단군이라는 친구가 있어요
단군
단군 할아버지에서 따온 거예요
아 그러니까 캐럿?
아니요
단군 할아버지
단군 왕검
우리 민족의
아아 오케이 오케이 오케이
보조선
오 오케이 오케이 오케이
짱
보스
그러니까 걔도 짱이에요?
친구도?
아니요 짱은 아니에요
근데 그거 따왔어요 자기가 뭐
아무튼 다른 걸로
그 친구도 인터넷 방송 캐스터인데
어렸을 때 엄청 많이 했어요 그거를
회사에서 많이 시켜가지고
단련이 됐어요
지금 엄청 잘해요
젊었을 때 너무 단련을 많이 했어요
맞아
그게 아까 얘기했듯이 운동이나 이런 거랑 똑같아
그럼 힘들었던 게
사실은 이게 재산이 되는 경우네요
젊었을 때 힘들었던 경험들이
그게 사실은 나는 god 하면서
우리 힘든 스토리 같은 거 얘기들 하면
신체적으로 나한테 힘든 거 하나도 없었어
왜냐면 난 벌써 미국에서 사회생활을 하던 사람이고
미국에서 내가
직접 벌어서 돈을 내지 않으면
집값 렌트 못 내지
전기세 못 내지
그런데 한국 가서 제일 힘들었던 건 이제
누구들의 귀한 자식들 4명을
나를 믿고 이렇게 줬는데
그 부담 어깨 무거운 게 그게 제일 힘들었었지
누구한테 딱 누가 봐도 굶고 있는데
얼굴이 다 이렇게 막 얼굴이 녹아내리고
대니는 거의 뭐 해골 바가지가 됐을 정도로
우리 다 그냥 살이 많이 빠져갖고
궁댕이 볼기 짝이 없어
갑자기 똥구멍이야 뭔지 알지
근데 뜻이 뭐냐면 진짜
너무나도 너무나도
골이 없어요
어 골이 없어
그렇기 때문에
그냥 구멍만 있어요
그때 뭐 그런 거 너무 웃긴 게
그때 나 순붕짬뽕 찍을 때 막
윗통 까고 어 몸 좋아요
그런데 그게 운동해서 가지고 그냥 살이 빠진 거야
못 먹어서
근데 근육은 잡혀 있으니까
근데 그런 게 제일 힘든 거지
신체적으로 난 힘든 건 없었어
그냥 엄마한테 내 얼굴을 사진을 보여주기 싫었었지
왜냐면 그러면 야 빨리 와
너 왜 얼굴 그렇게 됐어
무수척해
어 왜냐면 그러니까 한국 맨치마스는
89kg, 91kg였었는데
한 65kg?
90kg까지 내려가니까
보디빌더들은 좋아하겠지
팍팍 갈려지는 거
근데 그때는 살아남으려고 그렇게 된 거니까
근데 사회생활 막 하고 그림 관련해서 일을 하시다가
갑자기 이제 가수가 되신 게
스토리가
스토리가 있는 게 뭐냐면
사실은 저는 이제
어느 데서 취직돼서 이 그림 한 게 아니고
알다시피 미국에서는 프리랜스가 많잖아요
프리랜스로 하고
서핑하고 스케이트볼 바닷가에 있는 가게를
지배인이었어요
그거 하면서 거기서 이제 프리랜스로
디자인도 할 수 있으니까
그래서
그렇게 하다가 우리 누나가
한국에서 스타일리스트였었어요
아까 뵌 분
네
영화 스타일리스트
근데 그때 비트 알죠?
영화 비트
정우성
그 비트 촬영을 했을 때
어 맞아 맞아
따 나
그거 했을 때 누나가 그 촬영장소에 있는데
정우성 매니저가
누나가 키고리 갖고 있는데
거기에 사진 몇 개 있는 거야
얘 누구냐
어 마스크가 되게 특이하다
동생이라고
어디 동생이냐고
내 친동생
안 닮았잖아
노래 뭐 이런 거 할 수 있냐
어 하고
와서 오디션 봐갖고
하게 된 거죠
근데 원래 하시던 일이 있는데
어 왜냐면 내가 우리 엄마한테 말했어
이게 되게 큰 결정이잖아요
그때가 내가 이제 27이었어요
그래서 엄마가
너도 이제 한국 가서
너의 고향의 문화랑
한국 말도 좀 배워라
성공 안 해도 되니까 가서 그냥
네 인생의 인연을 가서 살아봐라
더 나이 들기 전에
오케이 하고 왔는데
IMF가 터진 거야
IMF가 터지고
소속사는 그냥 어디 갔는지 모르겠어
그래서 내가 아까 얘기했듯이
아 이러고 한국에 다시 가
내 친구들한테 뭐라 그래
나는 어떻게든 성공을 할 거야 해갖고
광고사에서 일을 하고
스토리보드 콘텐츠 이런 거 짜내고
그렇게 해서 된 거였어요?
그러다가 엑스트라로 CF를 날라나 찍었는데
그게 관심거리 돼갖고
이제 소속사에서 어 됐다 이제
해갖고 숭봉상무인과를 나오게 되고
GOD도 준비했고
그러면 이제 팀원들이 아무래도 좀
형님을 의지를 많이 했겠네요
진짜로 의지를 했지
부담이 컸을 것 같아요
그러니까 제 말이 그거예요
힘들었던 부분이 딱 그거라는 거잖아요
그거예요
그게 왜냐면 왜 힘드냐면
나한테 되게 충격적이었던 게 뭐냐면
처음으로 광고인은 딱 왔는데
사람들이 나한테 어 형 형 이러는 거야
미국엔 형 동생 없어
거의 다 이거잖아
난 우리 집에서 막내이기 때문에
형이 형 그러니까 그게 더 신기한 거야
나도 또 어른처럼 어이 걱정 마 이렇게
이걸 하는 거야
그런데 나도 미래를 모르고
난 한국 문화 자체도 모르고
한국 자체 라이프스타일을 모르는데
그때 장혁을 먼저 만났기 때문에
장혁
장혁한테 많이 의지를 났는데
난 했어 왜냐면
나는 사실은 인생의 선배지만은
한국에서는 걔네들은 난 초보야
그래서 애들한테 많이 배웠고 맨 처음에
미국에서는 다 반말하니까
매니저들한테 괜찮아 말 놔
나한테 그러다가 뭐
매니저들은 반말 놓고 그러니까
근데 동생들이 그러니까
형 광고에서는 그러면 안 돼
여기는 확실히 위 아래가 있어야 되고
선배 후배가 있어야 되고
형 동생이 있었기 때문에
형이 반말을 하려고 그러면 걔네들은
형 함부로 할 수도 있어 그래서
아이 괜찮아
근데 진짜 어느 날 나한테
함부로요?
어떻게든 나한테는
빨리 이거 해
그래서 조금만
야 새끼야 빨리 해 나한테 그러는 거야
나보다 어린 애가
그래서
그때 진짜 죽여버리고 싶었는데
근데 빨리 해 이게 이미 한국 문화에
이제 적응이 되니까 이제 기분이 나쁜 거잖아요
그 사람은 나한테 새끼야 그랬어
빨리 해 새끼야 그러는 거야
그래서
영어로 하면 뭐해요?
hurry up mother f**ker
그 정도예요?
그 정도죠
이거지 hurry up mother f**ker
hurry up mother f**ker
막 이거지
그래서 거기서 느낌이
어 내가 그 느낌이 너무 안 좋아 갖고
그래 나도 그렇게 돼야 되겠다
왜냐면 진짜 맨 처음에 한국 왔을 때는
나는 캘리포니아는 되게 사람들이 릴렉스 하잖아
맨 처음에 한국 왔으면 뭐
야리 같은 거 사려면
내 뒷산은각 주세요 그러면
나 돈 이렇게 끌어다니고
사실 담배 그 사람이 놔두고 그러잖아
그러면 어떤 사람이 가요?
천 원 놔두고 자기가 담배 갖고 가
나는 거기서 계속 기다리니까 계속 밀리고 밀리는 거야
그래서 애들이
형 그냥 질르고 형도 가야 돼
운전할 때도 형 그냥 빨리 가
야 빨간불 내 거 아니 형 그냥 가
빨간불은 아니에요
빨간불 이거 빨간불 이거 빨간불
형 그냥 빨리 가
빨리 가
이거 빨간불 될 거라니까 그냥 가라
끼지 않으면 지가 왔네
이게 이게 이제 한국 사람 되는 게
마음이 급하다는 게
거기서 그 워썸맨 편집이 딱딱딱
아
그리고 그때는 훨씬 또 뭐라고 해야 되지
공중도덕이 좀 낮았을 때잖아요
요즘에는 이제 다 지키잖아요 좀 순서를
예전에는 나 진짜 내가 한국에 맨 처음에 왔었을 때
지하철 내가 교대역 사거리에서 신사역 사거리까지
지하철을 타려고 그때는 이제 표를 받잖아요
줄 섰는데
계속 사람들이 앞으로 가는 거야 그러다가 하다가
어떤 남자애들 세명 키 되게 크고 딱 힙합처럼 있고
여자 이명인데
내가 이렇게 가려면 내 앞으로 딱 가는 거야
그래서 내가 내가 여기 다음 순서인데요
그래서 내가 어 세키 한국말 안 해?
그래서 내가 예? 그랬더니 한국말 잘 안 해
튀기 새끼들이 그렇지 뭐 그러는 거야
근데 어린 애들이 나보다 어려 100%
오 진짜 근데 내가 주먹이 이렇게 돼서 하고 싶은데
우리 형이 나한테 그랬어
한국에서는 너 주먹질하면 큰일난다
절대로 참아라. 그래서 참았지.
우협지 같아요.
참았어.
참았는데 가면서 그 여자가
미안해요.
그래서 내가 속으로 내가 얘기했어.
얘네들이 잘못한거야.
되게 마음 급하고
그 당시에는 그런게 있었는데 요새는 그런게 없어요.
요새는
나한테 누가 그런 말 없죠.
god 얘기도 들어보고
여러가지 이야기도 들어봤는데
사실 라이브 방송은
TV쇼에서 해보시고
라디오 많이 하셨잖아요.
라디오는 많이 했는데 인터넷 방송 자체는?
이건 처음인데요.
어떠세요?
나는 어색하지도 않고
여기서 하도 잘하고 편하니까
이건 거저돈 버는건데?
이 자식 괜찮은데?
여기 앉아서 사람들 앞에서
young man 하고
짱인거 같아.
제가 봤을 때는 왓섬맨이
라이브에 좀 최적화됩니다.
왜냐면 왓섬맨에서 보면은
옛날 얘기 길어지잖아요.
그럼 이제 자르잖아요.
수율이 좀 떨어지잖아요.
버려지는 것들을 안 버려지게끔 하는
팟캐스트를 하면
같이 할까?
팟캐스트를 하면 안 버려도 되잖아요.
옛날 얘기 같은 거.
본인의 생각이나 이런 것들을 말하실 때.
이것도 괜찮은 거 같아.
근데 여기 이렇게
난 지금 움직여야 돼.
지금 솔직히 해서
나 자꾸 이것도 들고 저기 가고 그러니까
뭔가 뭔지 알지?
잠깐만.
그럼 막 돌아다니면서 얘기하는 걸 좀.
나는 어디 가다가 딱 있으면 해갖고
어? 안녕하세요. 하면서
난 이렇게 말할 때. 계속.
계속 움직이고 한다면
이런 거 보고
이거 너무 귀엽고 이런 게 되게 좋아.
이렇게 만지고 움직이고
굽히고 막 이렇게.
이런 거 신기한 거 다 보고. 왜냐면 이게
봐봐. 내가 누구하고 대화를 나누면서
이걸 보는 거하고 말하는 거하고
나 혼자서 이렇게 보는 거하고
다른 게 내가 봤을 때
이거 느끼는 거랑 이 사람이 봤을 때
느끼는 거랑 다른 걸 난 그걸 알고 싶어.
아.
얘가 얘 봤을 땐 뭐 같아요?
뭐 그냥 뭐 문어.
난 봤을 땐 다른 것처럼 보여.
큰 명란점.
근데 사실 제가 라이브 방송을 하면은
한 5시간씩 앉아있어요. 그냥.
게임하면 7시 8시.
되게 침착맨이잖아.
그런 성격이기 때문에 그런 걸 할 수 있는 거야.
나는 사람들이 2라고 생각을 하는데
사실 제가 나가서는 2지만
집에서는 아이야.
집에서는 차분하게? 엄청. 말수도 별로 없고.
난 이제 일 끝나
집에 가. 했는데 뭐 한 8시야. 그러면
와이프랑 애기랑 뭐 이야기 나누고
father and daughter time. 여기도 딸 있잖아.
그 시간을 해.
그럼 나만의 시간을 한 두세 시간을
가져야 돼. I need my own time.
어렸을 때는 하도
내가 그랬잖아. 인종차별 때 하도 으덤하고
난 나 어디 나가는 걸 싫어. 집에서만
이렇게 하는. 그림 그리지 않으면
그 장난감이 없어. 난 그 장난감을 찰흙으로 만들든지.
스케이트볼 같은 거. 왜
서핑이랑 스케이트볼을 내가 시작했었냐면
어렸을 때 혼자 할 수 있는 거야. 혼자서도 할 수 있었어.
yes. 뭐 농구 같은 게
아니고 얘는 난 서핑은 바닷가 가면
나랑 파도야. 그럼 그
파도가 내 친구 돼. 스케이트볼은
그냥 비만 안 오면 돼.
그런 거를 해서 내가 혼자서 잘 놀아요.
혼자서 잘 놀고 혼자서
말도 잘 해. 그래서 할아버지 할머니들
아 이거 왜 이렇게 말하는 게
나 이제 이해해. 아 계속
말을 걸고 했던 게. 맞아 맞아.
그럼 뭐 팟캐스트를 좀 스타일에 맞춰가지고
돌아다니면서 그냥 걸으면서
얘기하는 걸 해도 재밌을 것 같은데 그냥
계속 쭉 걸으면서 그냥. 손님하고
그냥 팟캐스트를. 근데 그게 위험한 게 뭐냐면
거기서 이상한 일이
발생되면 어떻게 해. 이상한 일이요?
무슨 이상한 일. 많이 막 이상한 사람들
와서 뭐 이렇게 하는데. 왜냐면 그런 사람들이 있거든.
아 그거는 저도 생각을 하는 건데
그냥 거기까지인 거죠.
그지. 그지.
그러니까. 난 그런 게
나는 그래서 똥이 무서운
들어서 피하는 게 아니라 들어서 피하잖아.
나는 아무것도 안 하니까 매일 집에 있어.
괜히 나갔다가 어떤 사람들이
이런 사람들이 있고 저런 사람들이 있고 저번에도
촬영하는데 어떤 분 한 잔 하신 분인데
대단하지 마. 이게 나는 그냥
이런 거 저런 거보다 그냥
그냥 집에 있어. 아니 근데 되게
말씀 들어보면은 뭐 여러 가지
되게 재밌는 변수 때문에 사람들하고
소통하는 걸 되게 좋아하세요. 뭐 이런
생각도 들어보고. 맞아 맞아. 근데 또 그런 변수가
또 스트레스가 되기도 해요. 그렇지.
그런 양면성이 있네요. 그러니까
나는 예방을 하지.
일이 벌어진 다음에
빨리빨리 움직이는 거 할 수 있지만은
순발력으로. 하지만
그거보다 그렇게 하지 않기 위해서 예방을 하는
스타일인데. 예방을 해놓고 나중에
있는 거는 순발력으로 하고.
난 이게 막 사람 많아도
막 빠져나갈 수 있고 난 솔직히
어디다 던져놔도 난 살아남을 수 있을
놈으로 생각해요. 난 굶어도 되고 난 뭐
뭐 3일 안 먹어도 되고 막 그런데
이제 가족이 있어야 되는데 가족이
그렇게 못하지. 음
그러면은 지금 왓섬맨도 이제
새로 이제 시즌 2를 시작하시고 하면서
계속 새로운 걸 하세요.
근데 궁극적으로 인생에서
하고 싶은 목표 같은 것도 있어요?
너무 많아요. 나는 진짜
서핑 여행 같은 데도 많이 가고 싶고
스케이트볼 같은 것도 타는 데 많이
가고 싶고 난 내가 소집해서
모아놓은 그런 것도 다 큰 방에다
진열해놓고 싶고 뭐
이런 자동차 저런 자동차도 막 타보고
싶고 일이 되게 많은데
많이 포기했어. 음
어쩔 수 없지. 많이 포기해야 되는 게
그래도 그 생각만 갖고
있는 거 내가 그렸었던 그거
어렸을 때부터 하고 싶었었던 거 못한
것들을 머릿속으로 생각을 갖고
있으면 그거 자체도 난 웃음을 주게
해. 음 기분이 좋아져요? 기분이
좋아져. 음 못하더라도
난 그런 기회 있으면 난 이렇게
할 거야 라는 그거를 머릿속으로
그려도 난 너무 좋고
그래서 나는 옛날 그 당시
내가 제일 즐거웠을 때 음악들을
듣고 그 당시
물건들도 좋은 게 아직도 난
어렸을 때 못한 것들 아직도
하고 싶은 것들이 많기 때문에
그때 그걸 못 놓는 것 같아요. 근데
또 그런 것도 있는 것 같아요. 그걸 막상
해버리면 감흥이
끝까지 가진 않는 것 같아요. 음
그렇기 때문에 이렇게 하면 좋겠다 해서
아까 뭐 생각하셨을 때 뭐 행복감을
느끼고 그러면 이제 계속 행복감을 느낄 수 있잖아요.
맞아. 실현이 안 됐기 때문에. 맞아.
실현이 안 돼서 더 좋은 것들도
있더라고. 자 맞아요. 크리스마스는
난 내가 제일 좋아하는 날인데
11월달에서부터 크리스마스 때까지
갈 때가 제일 설레고 행복한데
크리스마스 끝난 다음에 섭섭해. 음
그거는 마찬가지로 내가
진짜로 뭐 갖고 싶은 거 있는데
그걸 못 가지면 더 갖고 싶지만 가진다면
그냥 가진 거야.
워섬맨도 찍을 때도 똑같은 거예요.
뭐 민속촌이나 로또골드나
뭐 이런 데 가는 게 중요한 게 아니고
거의 가는 길에서 그 과정이 난 재밌는 거.
네. 재밌는 거라서
내가 하고 싶은 것들을 생각만 해도
행복하다 일단은. 비슷한 예시가
될지 모르겠는데 저도 옛날에
리니지라는. 아 알지.
하고 싶은데
결제를 해야 돼요. 맞아. 매달.
근데 저는 그걸 못해요. 집에
인터넷도 안 돼 있고. 매달
낼 돈도 없고. PC방 가서 해야 되는데
조금 한다고 올라가시더라고요.
그러니까 이제 어떻게 하냐면 PC
그런 잡지 같은 거예요. 공략집 있어요.
그걸 계속 봐요. 맞아. 상상하는데
그게 리니지보다 재밌었던 것 같아요.
재밌다니까. 그게 더 재밌어요. 지금
돌이켜보면 내가 상상으로 하는 거예요.
이거를. 옛날에 뭐 삼국지
같은 게임 같은 것도 신작이
나온다고 하면 이제 공략집이
잡지에 나오거든요. 그럼 계속 읽는 거예요.
이거를 내가 생산한 방식으로 하는 건데
이게 실현이 되지 않아서
오히려 더 즐기거나
더 행복감을 느끼는 경우도
존재하는 것 같고. 맞아요. 내가 옛날에
스케이트보드를 너무 갖고 싶은 게 있었는데
그 잡지를 잘라서 그 당시에
박스 같은 걸 자르면 저거는 두꺼우니까
그 스케이트보드를 이렇게 잘라서
거기에다가 밥풀로 해서 이렇게 붙인 다음에
주머니에 갖고 다니면서 매일 이랬어요.
이렇게 하면서. 아 이 스케이트보드
타면 내가 이런. 노기할 거야.
막 하고 막 이렇게 해서
이걸 했는데
그게 재밌었다니까.
이게 약간 지금 스팀게임이나
이런 것도 너무 많으면 사람들이
좀 그런 생각을 해요.
쌓여있는데 하기가 싫다.
모두가 느끼는 감정이거든요.
또 어떤 갖지 못했을 때
더 재밌는 것들이 있다.
이런 걸 해볼 수 있을 것 같습니다.
인생 살아가면서 모든 걸 다 잊게 되면
허전할 거야.
허전할 거야. 희망도 없어지고.
그러면은 인간은
사는 게 유한하잖아요.
근데 이제 일론 머스크나 이런 사람들이
이제 더 오래 살 수 있는 방법을
있다고 얘기를 한단 말이에요.
그럼 뭐 신체 개조나
이런 방법이 나중에 제시가 될 수 있어요.
그러면 의향이 있어요?
나는 내 스스로 내가 오래 살 수 있을 것 같아서
나는 우리 가족을 해주고 싶어.
가족이 원한다면?
어. 나는 가족들 해주고 싶고
나는 뭐 하라고 주고 싶으면
나는 허리. 허리 디스크.
늙으니까 허리 디스크 사고서
한 4개 사고서 키가 한
1.7cm인가 2cm가 줄었어.
그거만 되면 난 나머지 스스로 내가 다 할 수 있으니까.
스스로.
스스로 내가 운동을 하고.
아 운동해서.
아 저는 차 개조하는 것처럼 스스로 다
스스로.
600만불의 사람처럼 이거 교체.
차고에서.
부품 있으니까 차고에.
알겠습니다.
아 이거 사실 처음에
god 얘기도 나누고
왓슨맨 얘기도 나누고
뭐 지금 현재 관심 있는 거 앞으로 좀 어떻게
문제에 대해서 좀 얘기를 나눠봤고
뭐 이제 시간을 좀 마무리해야 될 시간입니다.
어 이렇게 하는 거예요 이 방송?
원래 이렇게 하는 거예요.
괜찮았어요? 가야지 어떻게 가지마.
잘가
가지마
난 가재미 좋아해.
가지마 가지고 가재미.
베스트 오면은 선물을 드립니다.
여기서. 어 이거네 로봇콘.
그냥 여기 있는 거
멀리 찾지 않고 렛츠고.
우와
와 현금 만원 나왔습니다.
뱀.
뱀. 원래 다 돈 있는 거예요?
아니요. 다른 것도 있어요.
여러 가지 굉장히 많은 것들이 있는데.
요. 요.
뱀.
쇼. 왓슨맨은 왔어. 오늘은 어디?
우리 뭔지 알지.
침착맨이랑 즐거운 시간을 보냈는데.
워우.
진짜로 남다르게
사람이 침착하고. 뭐라고 또 하라고?
나 생방송인데 또 하라는 게 뭐야.
또 하래요. 미안해요.
미안해 다시 할게.
쇼. 왓슨맨은 왔어. 오늘은 어디?
침착맨 두 번 하는 거다.
침착맨하고 즐거운 시간을 보냈는데.
와갖고.
말은 좋은 이야기도 나누고.
이분이 왜 떴는지. 왜 이렇게.
한 지 오늘 배웠고.
만원까지 갖고 옵니다.
여러분들 뭔지 알죠?
왓슨맨은 계속 갈 테니까.
폴로. 라잇. 습스그라이브.
아니면 죽여버려면 뭔지 알지.
원. 듀. 쓰리.
뱀.
쇼. 안녕.